il
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro deux va
y peuvent à parler d'emploi féminin et
de chefs d'entreprises femmes avec mon
invité juliette bourrin bonjourbonjour
patrice vous est la fondatrice de notre
huile s'appelle el bosque est une
plateforme de l'entreprenariat féminin
ou au service des entreprises alors
bragon de nous que c'est elle bosse
alors elle bosse est une plateforme qui
met en relation les femmes freelance fin
les femmes entrepreneurs qui sont en
recherche de missions avec des
entreprises qui ont besoin de
flexibilité de renforts d'accord et
c'est vrai qu'ils ont besoin souvent les
autres baisses de flexible xt accord
pour employer des gens tout le temps
pareil à des missions et des voix la wii
vous replomber à ce besoin alors oui on
répond à ce besoin de flexibilité des
entreprises particulièrement aujourd'hui
en pleine crise de covin où les
entreprises ont des difficultés à se
projeter sur du recrutement pur donc
nous on est déjà une véritable
alternative à l'intérim et aux cdd et on
est là aussi donc pour apporter aux
femmes des missions donc en un véritable
support de prospection commerciale pour
elle
et surtout donc apporter aux entreprises
entreprises par dans cette agilité et
leur permettent de trouver du renfort
sur certains besoins souplesse quoi
exacte tout les ans dans la gestion
quand vous parlez de mission de quel
genre de mission par exemple il peut
s'agir alors non en fait on référence
toutes les compétences qui intéresse
entreprises que ce soit du support
commercial administratif comptable que
ce soit de la com du web on a par
exemple des missions actuellement de
création de sites internet de deux
supports en communication de community
management enfin c'est très très variés
et en plus notre plateforme s'enrichit
quotidiennement des nouvelles
compétences que noël bosseuse comme on
les appelle des pauses sur la plateforme
elle bosse sur les quais ça s'écrit eux
deux a le bo2 un
point fr on leur tronc pour le pour le
retrouver et alors et les personnes que
vous proposez aux entreprises voulez
vous dire recrutés ou vous les trouvez
comment alors déjà on a une typologie
très très large femmes qui peuvent être
intéressés par elle bosse que ce soit de
l'étudiante qui est encore à
l'université en école et qui a envie de
faire des missions sur des moments cours
ou de façon récurrente donc ça en un du
rédactionnel par exemple on a également
deux jeunes mamans qui ont envie de
travailler autrement ça peut être aussi
des femmes qui justement ont arrêté de
travailler où on était expats ou qui ont
suivi des conjoints sur la mobilité ou
qui sont en territoire isolé ça ce sont
c'est aussi une typologie qui répond
très bien aux missions delbos et puis
c'est aussi des femmes qui souhaitent
travailler autrement pour un meilleur
équilibre vie pro vie perso donc on a
vraiment cette cet objectif là
on peut aussi avoir des retraités oui
voilà l'interview
très intéressant ce que je dis pas ce
que c'est beau d'un côté du du côté de
l'entreprise ça répond à ce besoin de
souplesse et de flexibilité dont vous
parlez du côté des femmes puisque ce
sont des femmes a que que vous proposez
aux entreprises il ya en effet ce ce
cette évolution qu'on sent bien de
vouloir travailler autrement peut-être
d'être moins salariés c'est-à-dire
d'être obligé d'être là tous les jours
mais d'avoir des missions de flexibilité
aussi dans l'exercice du travail ça
c'est une notion assez importante ces
nouvelles mais fortin ça répond en tout
cas un besoin de liberté un souhait de
travailler autrement aujourd'hui on à
43% des femmes qui après le premier
confinement ont souhaité changer de
rythme de travail c'est madame figaro
qu'il indiquait à l'époque est également
une vraiment une belle progression de 2
des statut d'auto-entrepreneur entre
2019 et 2020 de 17 et demi pour cent
donc ce qui est quand même énorme donc
c'est aujourd'hui une autre façon de
travailler un mode beaucoup plus
flexible ou finalement peut s'extraire à
nouveau la voilà on est en région
parisienne on connaît bien le territoire
on connaît bien les embouteillages et on
sait que travailler autrement prendre
son ordinateur est allé en province
c'est une chance incroyable qu'on peut
aujourd'hui faire beaucoup plus bon
comme vous le à quoi vous l'attribué au
fond cette évolution c'est vrai que
peut-être que le le lac au vide et le
coffee de bonbons étaient des
révélateurs d'un souhait qui était
probablement plus profond oui oui je
pense que ça a accentué les choses ça
c'est sûr maintenant on a quand même
cette donnée inquiets 29% des femmes
aujourd'hui sont à temps partiel contre
lui pour cent des hommes donc il faut
quand même se dire que ça peut être
encore un choix parfois une obligation
de travailler à temps partiel d'avoir le
soin ou pas de s'occuper de ses enfants
mais en tout cas de faire ce choix là
donc donc aujourd'hui on accompagne en
tout cas chez elle bosse ce souhait de
travailler autrement d'avoir un rythme
de travail différent de pouvoir
travailler à temps plein si on le
souhaite tuer l'an démission ou bien de
on est aussi là pour accompagner les
femmes ce qu'on appelle des slashers
c'est à dire qu'elles peuvent avoir
plusieurs activités elles peuvent avoir
par exemple une activité passion qu'elle
développe dans le bien-être dans la
décoration fin d'autres types de mai qui
sont pas forcément très rémunératrice
dès le début qui demande beaucoup
d'investissement et donc
d'argent et du coup elles peuvent
prendre des missions sur elle bosse pour
compléter ajustements leurs revenus
la typologie ou des favoris qui se
dresse à vous l'avez dit c'est à dire
que ça va de ses dépôts dire de cet
autre chose dit c'est comme ça qu'on
sait pas tout à fait ça mais mais des
étudiantes aux
retraités avec oui en effet 7 et puis il
ya aussi entre les deux des femmes qui
ont ville de mener à la fois leur vie
professionnelle et leur vie familiale ça
reste quand même on reste quand même
dans un dans une période où c'est quand
même encore parfois les femmes plus de
la famille que les hommes mais oui bien
sûr on est un réquilibrage est loin de
nous chez elle bosse l'idée de dalé
opposé les hommes aux femmes des
compétences de savoir est on n'est pas
du tout dans un clivage l'idée vraiment
c'est d'accompagner la valorisation de
l'entrepreneuriat sur le marché du
travail est en effet bon il ya quand
même des constatations faites sur le
fait que en tout cas les femmes sont
toujours des mers et que le fait d'être
une maman ça peut aussi
impliqué de vouloir travailler
différemment est-ce que puisque vous
vous adressez aux femmes est ce que on
peut dire qu'il ya une une vision encore
genre et filtre anti aujourd'hui du
travail est ce qu est ce que les femmes
s'intéressent plus à encore à certains
secteurs ou est ce que ce sont des
secteurs que des hommes ou des femmes
pourraient reprendre les raisons il ya
encore des secteurs qui sont
majoritairement masculin comme le btp ou
voilà lyon l'idée c'est vraiment
d'accompagner en tout cas les femmes à
devenir chef d'entreprise c'est ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure puisque y est
pareil un déséquilibre aujourd'hui sur
l'entrepreneuriat 36 % sont des femmes
donc on en a encore de quoi encore 36 %
de nos photos pour ce chef d'entreprise
ça oui et donc du coup ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose sur lequel il faut
travailler accompagner et c'est aussi
une posture que l'on essaie de
de révéler en tout cas chez les femmes
chez elle bosse on fait aussi de
l'accompagnement donc on souhaite leur
permettre d'avoir une posture plus
affirmé qu'elle ose qu'elles aient une
meilleure confiance et estime
d'elle-même qu'elle est là ça joue
beaucoup oui elles sont joints dans
l'éducation d'ailleurs parce que les
défis y sont plus fortes que les garçons
à l'école et au fond les grandes écoles
etc elles sont mois présentent parfois
par par peur d'elle-même quoi oui alors
on voit bien aussi sur tout ce qui est
start-up levée de fonds etc où il est
plus difficile
aux femmes d'accéder à des levées de
fonds
mais également parce que
il ya une problématique de risques que
les femmes prennent peut-être plus à
coeur que les hommes enfin les hommes en
tout cas aux davantage plus d'ambition
mais au fil des ans c'est encore
douloureux donc il ya encore du boulot
oui oui c'est clair et c'est vraiment
aussi notre objectif que d'accompagner
les femmes là dedans et c'est l'essai
passionnant ça si je suis chef
d'entreprise bon pourquoi j'irais faire
appel à vous pour quoi d'abord vous
pourquoi des femmes plutôt que des
hommes alors on voit là c'est la
question qu'on nous pose et encore une
fois on n'est pas du tout dans ce soit
de d'opposer deux mais vraiment dans le
souhait de valoriser dans le but c'est
mon histoire un mois j'ai
voilà c'est ça et en fait c'est un peu
ça qui m'a qui nous amener à créer elle
bosse et à vouloir accompagner la mixité
dans les entreprises donc c'est
simplement un soin de rééquilibrage est
d'impliquer les entreprises dans notre
dans nos convictions que la mixité et y
est essentielle dans l'entreprise et est
encore une fois voilà on a vraiment ce
constat que moi j'avais fait à l'époque
pour moi même de dire qu' il n'est pas
toujours facile d'être une femme active
et de concilier sa vie professionnelle
familiale
voilà est de trouver un équilibre et vim
donc l'objectif alors dites moi on va
parler un petit peu d'où vous êtes vous
avez été je crois maman à ces jeunes
oui moi j'ai mes enfants à 23 ans j'ai
arrêté de travailler le bois vert été
trouvé
de fait même si on a fait des choix
c'était des choix familiaux avec le
morcellement si facile mais bon après je
me suis beaucoup investi dans ma ville à
l'époque la garde lui une vie
associative pas exactement une vie
associative très riche dans le domaine
de l'enfance de la folie non oui enfance
famille parentalité alors c'était ont
créé des ateliers pour accueillir les
jeunes mamans les aider à sortir de leur
solitude après la naissance de leur
enfant etc après si on était plutôt sur
la parentalité avec les écoles les
collèges et c'est donc on a fait des
conférences avec des pédopsychiatres
avec fait des collectes pour les restos
du coeur bon en tout cas ça m'a appris
énormément et ça aussi permis de faire
du réseau et de bien connaître les
réseaux féminins et les attentes des
femmes et puis après j'ai été freelance
dans le recrutement
voilà après quand même dans une grande
entreprise directement et puis j'ai été
salarié dans un grand groupe quelques
années en tant que responsable d'un
cabinet de recrutement dédié au
nucléaire d'accord voilà et puis on va
au bout de quelques années
je pense que comme beaucoup de crise de
la quarantaine où on remet les choses en
question on se dit et maintenant quelles
vont être les prochaines vont se passer
mes prochaines années c'est dur de
sauter le pape se dire ça y est je vais
créer mon nom c'était vraiment une envie
très forte chez moi d'abord
l'entrepreneuriat m'a toujours intéressé
accompagner les femmes aussi et
finalement l'idée est venue toute seule
c'est à dire que je me suis dit baye des
femmes comme moi y'en a plein et on a
plein de compétences point de savoir
être alors finalement on est vraiment
très très bien placé pour répondre aux
besoins de flexibilité des entreprises
donc en se disant que
on a des compétences on peut les mettre
en avant et les entreprises ont besoin
d'une journée deux journées et trois
journées par semaine d'accompagnement
sur certains sujets on est hyper hyper
flexible pour faire ça tout en gérant
notre vie familiale et personnelle à
côté donc serré la main comme en
proposent d'ailleurs elle bosse
c'est un côté un peu innovant puisque
aujourd'hui il existe des plateformes de
freelance bien entendu sur des métiers
dédiés ou sur des niches comme des
niches sur fall les étudiants des choses
comme ça et il existe des réseaux
féminins on est partenaires d'ailleurs
de oui la fille de bill owens un des
réseaux qui accompagnent ces les femmes
sur l'entrepreneuriat mais nous notre
ambition ça a été vraiment de proposer
des missions parce que vraiment quel est
l'enjeu on a souvent à une compétence
métier on a mais est-ce qu'on est
commercial pour autant pas forcément et
ça c'est vraiment le nerf de la guerre
quand même d'aller chercher du travail
donc elle bosse à cette mission de
rayonner
et d'aller convaincre les entreprises
qu'on est très très bien placé pour
répondre à leurs besoins écoutez merci
beaucoup je vais vendre elle bosse
évidemment il ya un site internet pour
vous retrouver sinon je pense que vous
êtes à feucherolles tout à fait donc on
a cette plateforme surélevée ce point fr
vous pouvez déposer un profil déposer
une mission et tout se fait très
simplement et intuitivement merci
beaucoup d'inertie novatrices
[Musique]